when you have casual conversations with
people you typically emphasize the like
final performance and when you talk
about these high profile achievements we
don't often spend much time scrutinizing
the sample efficiency and one thing that
we've been kicking around a little bit
is actually can we come up with these
empirical test Suites or benchmarks that
really put a data efficiency at the
forefront you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
MSRs New York City lab is home to some
of the best reinforcement learning
research on the planet but if you ask
any of the researchers they'll tell you
they're very interested in getting it
out of the lab and into the real world
one of those researchers is dr. Akshay
Krishna Murthy and today he explains how
his work on feedback driven data
collection and provably efficient
reinforcement learning algorithms is
helping to move the RL needle in the
real-world direction that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
akshay krishnamurthi welcome to the
podcast thanks for having me
let's start by situating you're a
principal researcher at MSR in New York
City and part of what I'd like to call a
small but tactical unit working on
reinforcement learning in real-world
settings both for the short term you
called that translational and the long
term so to kick things off today tell us
how these two approaches are different
and how they're being tackled in your
lab and then talk about how they're each
making an impact on the science of
reinforcement learning both practically
and - theoretically I like to categorize
our projects in terms of the time
horizon with which we might push things
into product and the first kind of
bucket here is more translational
efforts these are the kinds of things
that maybe we hope to put in production
in the next year or two years and then
the other bucket is maybe more blue sky
kind of efforts things that maybe are
five years out or ten years out or you
know just more high-risk kind of
projects let me talk a little bit about
the translational stuff yeah so our
group maintains and develops this RL
system that is currently deployed in
production in several settings most of
these are recommendation kind of
settings and we're constantly adding
features we have this amazing group of
engineers and data scientists working on
this product and the researchers are
adding features to the system based on
new research and also kind of based on
requests and feedback from product
groups so this is I think a really cool
way to do research where you're working
with a product group on some deployments
and then they come to you and say hey we
also want to do X and then we think
about it and we're like oh we actually
don't know how to do X so then we like
go do some research and try and figure
out how to do that kind of thing and
then we circle back with the part of
group maybe in six months or one year
when we figure out something and one
example of this is actually this project
we did on recommendation when the sort
of decision space that the algorithm is
operating over is very very rich and
typically like of a combinatorial nature
so the prototypical example here is
personalized news so you don't just
choose like one story to show to the
user you might choose like ten stories
and you have to rank them so now your
decision space is much much more
complicated and it becomes much more
difficult statistically to figure out
what sort of recommendation rules are
better and so we sort of came up with
some technique that's inspired by a lot
of literature in learning theory
community and we brought this back to
the news team and I think in the last
one year this has sort of been making
its way to production in this system
that we're running so that's kind of
like what the translational efforts look
like and the other side of the story is
this blue sky or long term stuff and
here I think we're not that attached to
applications when I think about this
style of research I mostly am thinking
about what are the really challenging
problems in reinforcement learning and
how can we come up with models and
algorithms that address those issues I
don't really know the timescale that
these things will pan out right I think
these problems are super hard I'm
definitely not the only one thinking
about them you know we're making
progress but it's just not exactly clear
to me when these things will make it to
applications but the hope is that you
know as we build our understanding we
will be able to do that
well let's situate you akshay
researchers often live at an
intersection or they like to say they do
so what's your address
where does your research passion lie and
what gets you up in the morning yeah so
these days I'm pretty interested in the
statistical issues around reinforcement
learning but this I think for me is part
of a bigger story I've always been
interested in interactive learning which
typically when I tell this to people
they think of something else but I
usually use this to refer to any sort of
learning setting where the algorithm
engages in feedback driven data
collection and this is I think one of
the central problems in reinforcement
learning the agent operates in this
world makes a bunch of decisions and the
decisions it makes influence the data
that the agent has and so part of the
challenge is actually learning to make
the right decisions to collect the right
data so that's sort of where I came from
I've always
been interested in a sort of broader
topic of designing algorithms to collect
the right data and the last four or five
years it's mostly been about
reinforcement learning because that's a
very hard version of that problem well
let's go a little deeper on the
theoretical for a moment and talk about
what you referred to as incentive
structures in scientific circles so what
is the current landscape look like
particularly with regards to how
benchmarks are set up and measured and
how we might be thinking differently
about incentive structures so that the
reinforcement learning ball moves
forward I think data efficiency is one
of the core issues in RL I was just
mentioning this and so I think most
researchers are interested in moving
towards real-world applications and the
ones that people typically kick around
our recommendation high precision
medicine personalized medicine robotics
these kinds of things and in these
settings we may not have the luxury of
collecting millions or billions of
interactions before we produce some
high-quality policy so I feel the
real-world applications are quite
different from the kinds of simulated
environments that we are currently using
for benchmarking and don't get me wrong
the benchmarks are amazing they've
really pushed the field forward but I
also am kind of mindful about the way
benchmarks also influenced the community
so there's some kind of feedback loop
here and right so these benchmarks kind
of over emphasizes quality of final
policy at the expense of how much
experience did you need to get there and
I think when you have casual
conversations with people you typically
emphasize the like final performance and
when you talk about these high profile
achievements we don't often spend much
time scrutinizing the sample efficiency
and one thing that we've been kicking
around a little bit is actually can we
come up with these empirical test Suites
or benchmarks that really put a data
efficiency at the forefront right and I
think these are kind of things that
hopefully will catch on and actually
like nudge the community back to
thinking about statistical issues right
let's get down to the nitty-gritty and
talk about math
the beating heart of RL research is
algorithms and you told me they need to
be able to do three things so I'm gonna
have you get down to the nitty-gritty on
some impressive algorithms you've been
working on in a minute but first give us
a framework for the research what things
are reinforcement learning algorithms
supposed to be able to do and where are
we on the path towards cheap fast good
pick three instead of pick two this is
actually something I took from one of
John Langford's talks and the core
capabilities of RL algorithms are credit
assignment which is when you make a
sequence of decisions and as observe a
certain outcome you know how to allocate
like which decisions were responsible
for that outcome and this is not so easy
because maybe you did 100 things and
then at the end you know you are at a
pot of gold and is it because you turned
left over here or turned right over
there or whatever that's credit
assignment the other issue is
exploration so you're an agent you're in
some complicated environment you run
around for some time if you run around
blindly you will not you know find all
the corners of every nook and cranny
that you might need to you know solve
your problem so you have to explore the
environment and the other one is
generalization if your environment is
relatively complicated you might not
actually see the same thing twice and
what you'd hope for is that the skills
you learn and the the patterns you pick
up in one place can transfer to other
situations so this is this thing that my
colleague Dipendra always talks about
he's saying I learned how to bike in
Brooklyn and when I go to Amsterdam I
should also know how to bike so we
should be able to generalize our
experience to new experiences okay so
those are the three capabilities and
when you take any pair of these right
now we have relatively mature algorithms
that often are used in production and we
have like a pretty solid theory for how
to do two of three so I think the one
that is pretty common these days is
doing credit assignment and
generalization without exploration
mm-hmm and so what's going on in a lot
of these policy search kind of
algorithms like maybe you've heard of
policy gradient methods and so what
these algorithms do is you have some
current policy you execute it perhaps
with some No
is to sort of deviate a little bit and
you pick up some signal about what local
changes to your policy are doing and
this is sort of solving the credit
assignment this deviation is addressing
the credit assignment aspect and your
policy is may be parametrized by some
neural network and so that's handling
the generalization aspect you don't have
to keep track of every single state you
might see so then you you do these local
deviations and you make small
improvements on your policy so these
algorithms are actually pretty effective
and they work really well in like
continuous control kind of problems but
they kind of are doing a local search
and so they don't really work very well
in problems where you have to do very
sophisticated exploration but maybe one
research question is can we bring an
exploration into these style of
algorithms we certainly don't have
robust algorithms for doing all three
the blue sky optimism is that we can do
all three yeah and I think even in this
cheap fasting good the definitions keep
moving so certainly I think now like if
you think about with the advent of the
internet we can access information very
cheaply very quickly and it's very high
quality yeah and it's very different
from maybe what it was thirty years ago
or something rightly so the definitions
keep moving and that's that's fine but I
think we should actually be optimistic
to push for these things that maybe seem
almost impossible
[Music]
well let's talk about some specific
algorithm since we're on that track
right now
first one is one you call policy cover
by inductive decoding or PC ID and the
exploration around this work was
published in 2019 in an ICML paper
titled ready provably efficient
reinforcement learning with rich
observations tell us about PC ID and how
it moved the needle on provably data
efficient methods but were the key
claims and contributions of this work
this paper is part of a longer effort on
this sort of blue-sky track of designing
algorithms with these three capabilities
of credit assignment generalization and
exploration so in a ICML 2017 paper we
came up with a more general theory for
some sort of way to build algorithms
with these three capabilities and some
kind of environment assumptions under
which these things are possible but the
algorithms in that paper are not
particularly practical so this ICML
paper 2019 is more focused towards
practicality although I would still
consider this relatively theoretical
paper so what do we do so we have this
new algorithm it's called PC ID and we
can use it to find near optimal policies
for a restricted class of environments
that we call a block MVPs and it does
this in a provably efficient way both in
terms of the amount of experience it
requires and the total computation and I
think one thing I do want to highlight
here is that these block MVPs they're
relatively structured environments but
they do actually require the agent to
demonstrate all three of those core
capabilities of credit assignment
generalization and exploration but the
other thing I want to highlight is the
phrase provably efficient that I
mentioned I don't want to suggest that
other algorithms do not have these
capabilities what I'm just saying is we
are able to prove that our algorithm
does perhaps the key claim is we're
proving that this algorithm has some
data efficiency guaranteed and and that
is something I kinda want to emphasize
so let me tell you like the high level
of the approach its superficially
similar to I think what's
now a relatively common strategy which
is to create some auxilary supervision
based on what the agent is doing and use
that to identify some kind of compact
representation of the world and then use
the compact representation to drive an
exploration module so the way we sort of
realize this is our representation is
like a discrete latent state and that's
why this this thing is called decoding
we decode the latent state of the world
and then we run one of these algorithms
that can do exploration and credit
assignment but not generalization on the
decoded latent state so that's like the
high-level idea and to explain where I
have to tell you about this block MVP
model okay
the model is this kind of stylized
setting in which there exists some
latent state space that's relatively
small in the literature they might call
this a tabular state space but these
states are never observed by the agent
instead the agent will be in a state but
it doesn't know that and it will see an
observation which is like sort of
emitted from a distribution associated
with this state and the observation
might be extremely high dimensional and
very very rich but the observation might
actually have enough information for the
agent to figure out what its latent
state is but the agent sort of doesn't
know how to do that compression so
there's some mapping in the world that
takes observations and maps them to the
latent state and if the agent only knew
this mapping it could just run one of
these tabular methods which do
exploration and credit assignment but
don't do generalization so this model
kind of encourages a little bit of a
like a factored approach where you do
the generalization part you know to map
observations to state and then you do
the other two things using a technique
we already know okay
the key challenge here is that you never
observe the latent state so it's not
that clear how are you going to learn
this decoder and this is sort of where
the auxilary supervision comes in so we
use supervised learning to train a
predictor to predict some other stuff
and somehow we show that when you
predict this other stuff you recover the
latent state
the algorithm proceeds in this like
forward manner so you take like a
hundred steps and then you reset and
then you take a hundred steps and you
reset and each one of these is an
episode and so we can assume we have the
decoder at stage H some time step and
we're gonna use the decoder at the
previous time to learn the decoder at
the current time and the way you do it
is you take the observation at the
current time and you predict the
previous action and the previous latent
state decoded state right you can
imagine it kind of recovers the dynamics
of the world because the reason you're
seeing this observation now is because
you were in that state yesterday and you
took that action yesterday so you
recover like the backward dynamics of
the process and because the dynamics are
governed by the latent state only you
kind of learned this compression and
then once you have the latent state at
stage H we learn how to visit every
state that you could possibly reach at
stage H and then that gives you a good
data coverage so that's like the
exploration component you get good data
coverage at stage H and you use that to
drive the process of learning the
decoder at the next stage so the PC ID
supervision is predict the previous
learned state and action from the
current observation okay so what do we
prove we prove that if you are in a
block MVP with not too many latent
States
not too many actions per stage and the
time horizon is not too long and then
there's something like technical
assumptions we prove that this algorithm
will find some way to visit every state
of the world with good probability
without too many samples so the number
of samples will be polynomial in the
number of latent states that time
horizon the number of actions all these
sort of relevant quantities and then we
learn how to visit every state of the
world which is solving the exploration
problem right and the generalization
component is baked in because this is a
block ntp and you have to do a decoding
on the computational side we operate in
this sort of is called the Oracle model
of computation so we assume that you
have a class of functions maybe it's
like a neural network or some
and that you can solve supervised
learning problems over this neural
network and that's where this auxilary
supervision comes in we train a neural
network or whatever to map raw
observation to previous state action and
we assume that you can actually solve
those classification problems and so
that's the computation let me just
mention the last piece which is the
first one where we actually ran some
experiments okay because this algorithm
is not super practical but not super
impractical either it's somewhere in the
middle like Goldilocks line yeah it's
what that we felt like we could
implement so the experiments I think are
more of a proof-of-concept that it is
actually doing something sensible than
anything else and what we show is that
we sort of concoct this kind of very
very difficult environment for
exploration and we run these algorithms
that don't do any exploration and they
fail obviously and then we run an
algorithm that we give it cheating
access to the latent state and we run an
exploratory algorithm so this is like an
algorithm that does exploration and
credit assignment but not generalization
and it does extremely well and then we
run our algorithm which does like not
much worse than that thing okay so it's
like the first one is like obviously not
going to work the second one is
obviously going to work and the question
is how close are we to like the skyline
that we could hope to achieve and so we
are getting there and but we're solving
it that harder problem where you have to
do the decoding okay and that was 2019
we're all the way into 2020 since then
you haven't sat around on your
algorithms you have a new paper in the
pipeline with another algorithm that you
think is actually pretty cool the paper
is called kinematic state abstraction
and provably there's that word again
efficient rich observation reinforcement
learning that's a mouthful and also a
math full in this paper you present
another algorithm called Homer tell us
about Homer and how it moves us closer
to solving for x if x equals robust
real-world reinforcement learning and
again feel free to show your work yeah
so Homer is I would think of it as an
improvement on PC id but the high level
claims are
kind of similar so we're still working
in the block MDP on a technical level
we're actually able to remove some of
these technical assumptions that I
didn't really explain to you in the
previous story but those are actually
required by the PC IDs theory and we can
actually show that PC ID empirically
fails when some of those things are not
satisfied so that's actually kind of
important but I think there are two
perhaps more important points about
Homer
so Homer is much much more robust in
practice and part of the reason is that
in PC ID we're trying to use the current
observation to predict the previous
state and the previous action now we
don't have access to the previous state
so we predict the previous predicted
state okay and this can cause some
catastrophic failure when your previous
predicted state is wrong okay so you're
trying to predict something that you're
predicting yourself which causes some
sort of bubbling of errors that doesn't
work very well and so in Homer we use a
different auxilary supervision problem
that does not rely on the previous one
we still do this kind of inductive thing
but we train this decoder for time H and
then we like throw it away and then we
train a completely new decoder for time
H plus one and so this makes the
algorithm somehow much much more robust
and much less prone to these kind of
propagating errors which is a very very
common problem in reinforcement learning
the other thing that we're doing in
Homer which is I think empirically very
important is in PC ID we are using the
latent state space that we build we
build like a dynamics model over the
latent state space and we do what they
call model-based planning and this is
also prone to failure when your model is
wrong okay so you're trying to plan in
your model to reach some state but your
model is wrong and so you just
completely fail and in Homer we replace
this planning module with like a policy
search module that operates again on the
raw observations so again here we're not
using the decoders we were just saying
we've collected a good data set that
covers the whole world and we can use
the data to train a machine learning
model to do the things we want to do so
those are the two reasons that Homer is
like a empirical and in some ways the
theoretical improvement
but the other more important point is
that in the homer project we've
identified a new structural notion that
we think might be useful in the design
of other algorithms and this is the also
this first part of the title which is
this kinematic state abstraction it's
kind of some property of an environment
where you might say two states of the
world are very similar if the dynamics
to and from those states are the same
you should be able to collapse these two
things together because if one policy
gets to 1 it also gets to the other so
for the purpose of exploration these two
states are very coupled and for the
purpose of forward prediction they're
also very coupled because they have the
same dynamics going forward and so this
kinematic state abstraction is a way to
formalize this and it's kind of easy to
show that in block mvps all the
observations coming from a latent state
are tied together they induced the same
forward and backward dynamics this idea
also inspires this new supervised
learning auxilary supervision problem
that we use here so this prediction
problem is it's what they call
contrastive learning so what you're
going to try and do is you're going to
splice data sequences together in some
real and fake way and you're going to
try to predict which ones are real and
which ones are fake so so I'm the agent
I see some observation I take an action
I see some next observation that's a
real transition so I have an observation
action observation triple now I made
some new place in the world a new
observation I take a different action I
see a another observation let me swap
the last two observations between these
two triples those are fake transitions
right and now if I can just somehow
train a model to predict what's real and
fake from this crazy data set that I
just like made-up right but I know the
label because I'm doing the splicing so
I train a supervised learning model just
a classifier to predict what's real and
what's fake if you think about it you
can kind of just pick out the transition
operator because you know what a real
transition is now and that means you
know what the distribution of the next
state is going to be given your current
state in action right and again we can
show that somehow when you solve this
problem you kind of are decoding the
latent state and then like sort of a lot
of the stuff that we do with PC IDs is
going through again on the empirical
side it's still
a relatively toy experiment but we're
more serious about comparing with the
algorithms that people are running in
practice there was one algorithm that
was pretty good so this is one of these
policy search methods when you attach on
an exploration module based on this idea
called random network distillation
so it's this chain of like 100 actions
so this thing got like 2 like level 25
or 30 or something but Homer just
crushed the whole thing because it's
kind of designed to do so I think it's
in some ways demonstrating what is a
very difficult exploration problem yeah
the algorithms that people typically use
do not solve those hard exploration
problems and Homer is sort of
constructed to do so and does it
[Music]
let's talk briefly about this section in
every academic paper that addresses
research limitations and what scientists
are still working on in general what big
challenges remain in this process or
pipeline of algorithmic perfection and
how are you moving into unlit spaces to
resolve them let's think about this on
the theory side in the empirical side so
on the theory side I think it's becoming
important to identify more expressive
models that emphasize the need for these
core capabilities of generalization
exploration and credit assignment to
date we've been working on the block MVP
model which it certainly does these
things but it's quite limited in many
ways so a lot of problems tend to have
like a continuous but low dimensional
latent state and this is not captured by
the Bloch MVP but we're also thinking
about like somehow substantially more
expressive models so we have some some
new proposal for model that's like
exponentially more expressive than the
Bloch MTP okay and whether we can build
algorithms for those things so like
Homer and P CID really are leveraging
this discrete latent state space in some
very very strong way and because they're
so attached to the model they don't
really work in the real world like your
real world does not have that block MVP
structure and then what happens right
but the other frustration here is that
we kind of know that some modeling
assumptions are required for provable
sample and computational efficiency and
so the question is what are the
assumptions that are relevant to
applications and perhaps we should just
keep expanding until we cover most
things but it might not actually work in
that way like maybe we'll have to sort
of fragment and say ok for this type of
application we're gonna focus on this
set of assumptions which are relevant
and come up with a specialized set of
algorithms and so on so that's kind of
the theory side I think we are sort of
pushing on like more expressive models
and algorithms that address more general
settings on the empirical side Homer and
PCI D are very much algorithms designed
by theoreticians and there's a question
of whether we can make them more
empirically effective I think there are
problems that do have something close to
block MVP structure and if we can make
these algorithms
somehow more natural more robust more
practically viable maybe we can start
pushing towards those kind of problems
and so we have an ongoing effort around
this where we're trying to you identify
some problems that might have the kind
of structures that Homer is sort of
exploiting and also trying to make Homer
somehow a little bit more data efficient
and these kind of things it's about now
that I always ask what keeps you up at
night both figuratively and literally
reinforcement learning is a bit of a
rock star when it's in a controlled or
simulated environment but once it hits
the open world the state space gets real
as we might say so what could possibly
go wrong Akshay and how are you working
from the beginning to ensure that it
doesn't well to be honest what usually
keeps me up at night is some like bug in
a proof or something in my code that's
not working and this has been especially
true in the recent months because I've
been like working very hard on this
fairly delicate proof and keep getting
stuck like every day so mostly I can't
sleep because I like cannot solve my you
know technical problem on the higher
level in terms of I think what could go
wrong I'm definitely aware that when you
pursue these sort of blue-sky efforts
there necessarily pretty high risk and
it could be the case that when you take
this theory first approach or even when
you are thinking about reinforcement
learning in the way that we're thinking
it just might not pan out so it just
could be the case that we push on this
for you know five years ten years and
then we just hit a dead end and that
would kind of be depressing but I think
it's part of what happens when you do
this kind of high-risk stuff yeah but
I'm also a bit reassured that you know
RL is a very very popular topic we have
a large community of incredibly
brilliant and amazing people that are
working on these problems and everyone
is tackling them with a different
approach in different perspective so
even if what we are trying to do doesn't
really pan out or doesn't do the things
that we want I think we will find
something that makes sense as a
community and from like a scientific
perspective that sort of I think keeps
me sane and I always have conversations
with people about this kind of stuff
like when I give a talk about our
they're like well do you really think
this is gonna pan out and I say I don't
know but like someone should try it
right so I think there's a real risk
that maybe these approaches don't make
sense and obviously we're thinking about
when they do make sense and trying to
make them make sense but maybe they will
not work right and that kind of keeps me
up at night a little bit but usually
it's the more technical stuff the other
concern about I think which is sort of
what you're talking about is when we
deploy these algorithms in the real
world what could go wrong I certainly
think a lot of things could go wrong and
there's a lot of things to be concerned
about like you know there's biases
there's safety issues there's fairness
issues and there's like become a very
vibrant community of people working on
those kind of problems
I think we're so far from applications
like I don't encourage anyone to deploy
Homer anywhere but I think I would say
that you know MSR has brilliant people
working on these kind of issues and I
think if and when we do get closer to
deploying something I am super fortunate
to feel like I can go talk to them and
like loop them in and see like what
should we be doing and I don't claim to
be an expert on those things at all so I
would just want to take advice from
other people on these kind of things
well it's story time here on the
Microsoft Research podcast so let's hear
yours what got you started in high tech
what was your academic path toward
research and how did you land in New
York City or at least post kovat the
home office in Brooklyn working on
reinforcement learning for Microsoft
Research yes so I grew up in a pretty
technical family I was born and raised
in Silicon Valley both of my parents
were engineers my brother is a computer
scientist so I think it was kind of in
the cards that said I didn't think I
wanted to be an academic probably
through most of grad school so when I
went to college I kind of had more of an
entrepreneurial bent I think this is
super natural for people in Silicon
Valley they all kind of want to do that
you hear about all these tech stars and
so on
so I didn't really think I wanted to be
an academic I was you know hacking on
random startup be project ideas in my
dorm room and stuff I did some industry
internships at tech startups and these
kind of things and I actually didn't
really like it so kind of what happened
is I did those things and I didn't and
and then I did a research project in
undergrad and then I also had this
amazing opportunity to spend a summer in
Tel Aviv doing a research project with
the professor there and that was like
super fun and really kind of pushed me
towards going to grad school and then my
last summer of grad school I was like
super fortunate that Alec and Miro like
invited me to do an internship and they
were just like hey do you want to come
spend the summer in New York doing
internship and I was like yeah that
sounds amazing and so I did that I
really like fell in love with the lab
since then like I think John has really
been an advocate for me so he lankford
like John Langford yeah so he like
encouraged me to apply for a postdoc he
was on my thesis committee he wrote a
letter for me so I came back for a
postdoc and then I spent two years as
assistant professor at UMass and then he
sort of encouraged me to come back as a
researcher I had to do this
advertisement at a conference about MSR
and I think the thing that is real is
like I've been there for three different
stages of my life and I keep coming back
so it is like really a glorious place to
be to do research and I love it
a lot so I think having these people
like Alec Agarwal Mira Dudek John
Langford they have been super
inspirational they're really like role
models for me and have really like given
me an opportunity to you know be here
and succeed and so on
what's one interesting thing we don't
know about you I leave it open-ended so
it can really be anything maybe it's a
personal characteristic or life event
that impacted your career or life maybe
it's a side quest or a hobby that
defines you outside your scientific work
or maybe just something fun or funny
that people might not suspect about you
yes I was actually discussing this
question last night with my partner and
the conclusion is that I'm pretty cliche
for like a tech bro
so I I do all the things that like you
know the San Francisco startup people do
I like to rock climb I play Ultimate
Frisbee I read a ton of sci-fi I am
rereading the three-body problem right
now which is just the excellent book I
cannot recommend it enough I'm also kind
of a foodie so in the pre kovat Times
Sid Sun and I would frequently sneak out
of the office to grab
you know fancy sweets and being in New
York there's just like tons of amazing
restaurants and dessert places to go to
so when I go to conferences I almost
always bring my climbing equipment and
they're starting to be like a group of
people that are in this crew of machine
learning climbers and we typically go
check out the local bouldering gyms or
maybe even go to like outdoor spot for
climbing and there's also obviously a
bunch of foodies in the m/l community so
we have a small group of people who go
check out like you know Michelin star
restaurant and stuff and so the academic
lifestyle is kind of great for those
kind of things what's the biggest thing
you've climbed so I mostly Boulder so
the biggest thing I climbed is not very
tall and mostly I actually do like
indoor bouldering so you know these
climbing gyms are cropping up everywhere
at Europe's last year me and a friend
went to so this was in Vancouver there's
just like you know world-class
bouldering area just north and Squamish
yes and so we went bouldering in
Squamish it was a bit raining so the
rocks were kind of wet what do you mean
we couldn't do anything no I think I'm
also not that good so the outdoors is
really just when you kind of get
humiliated yeah nature slams you and I
think the other thing is like the way
they do this grading the grading
outdoors is not commensurate with the
grading indoors so you kind of get
humbled
we need an algorithm for that yeah well
as we close and this has been super fun
I'd like you to dream out loud about the
future for a minute and give our
listeners a vision for next gen
reinforcement learning
I sometimes frame this now is if you're
wildly successful what will you be known
for at the end of your career and how
will the research you and your
colleagues have done made an impact on
the world both to the scientific
community and people at large so I
really hope that we can be involved in
the development of data efficient
empirically effective reinforcement
learning algorithms I think it's a
little bit hard to predict where they
will be effective so this is this
lamppost sort of phenomenon that
we were talking about the other day I
don't know what all the applications
might be for such algorithms if we have
them and this is part of this
constrained thinking we're like you know
we think about applications that our
current technologies can solve and we
don't think about applications that may
be new technologies might enable looking
under the lamppost is this story or it's
like a metaphor so there's person and
they lose their keys it's the night time
they're looking for their keys under the
lamppost because that's the only place
where they can see even though they are
a hundred percent sure that is not where
they lost their keys it's just where
there's light so this is this thing of
you know we work on the things that we
know we can do and the applications that
we think about are the things that are
like just just beyond our grasp but
maybe if we have some radically new
technology the set of applications will
just really open up and we cannot really
predict what those things might be I
think it would be really awesome to be a
part of that effort and see what kind of
things open up but it would be really
amazing to see that these algorithms do
have like a positive impact on the world
akshay krishnamurthi this has been more
fun than a podcast about algorithms
should be thank you so much for coming
on thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Akshay
krishnamurthi and the very latest in
reinforcement learning visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]